- Bienvenido de nuevo a "Entendiendo la Información
y Computación Cuántica." Mi nombre es John Watrous, y soy el Director Técnico
de IBM Quantum Education.
Esta es la quinta lección de la serie, y es la primera lección de
la segunda unidad de la serie, que trata sobre Algoritmos Cuánticos.
En esta unidad, investigaremos
las ventajas computacionales de la información cuántica, es decir, veremos
qué podemos hacer
con computadoras cuánticas y las ventajas que potencialmente podrían tener
sobre las computadoras clásicas.
Nos vamos a centrar en lo que podemos hacer con una sola computadora cuántica, en lugar de un entorno
distribuido, por ejemplo,
donde múltiples computadoras cuánticas interactúan a través de algún tipo de red.
De hecho, existen ventajas cuánticas en entornos distribuidos, donde la comunicación y
la criptografía entran en juego,
pero no vamos a estar
hablando de esas cosas en esta unidad.
Esta unidad trata sobre algoritmos cuánticos que se ejecutan en computadoras cuánticas individuales.
Empecemos con una pregunta natural. ¿Qué ventajas podría
ofrecer potencialmente una computadora cuántica?
La principal es que las computadoras cuánticas podrían ofrecer soluciones más rápidas a algunos problemas computacionales.
El tiempo es valioso, y aunque las computadoras que
usamos todos los días son bastante rápidas, siguen siendo demasiado lentas
para resolver ciertos problemas computacionales, simplemente por la dificultad
computacional inherente de esos problemas.
Este potencial de que las computadoras cuánticas nos permitan resolver problemas que las computadoras clásicas
son demasiado lentas para resolver
es realmente lo que ha impulsado
la investigación en algoritmos cuánticos durante las últimas décadas.
Hay otros recursos computacionales
además del tiempo que se pueden considerar, como la cantidad de memoria de computadora requerida para los cálculos,
pero las computadoras cuánticas no pueden
ofrecer mucho ahorro en términos de memoria, resulta que la memoria de las computadoras clásicas es bastante económica
en comparación con la memoria cuántica. Así que simplemente no hay
mucha promesa aquí.
También podríamos pensar en otros recursos, como la cantidad de energía
necesaria para la computación, pero en realidad no necesitas
mucha energía
para computar de forma clásica, especialmente si estás
dispuesto a ir más despacio.
Así que realmente es el tiempo
requerido para los cálculos lo que es nuestro enfoque principal.
Aquí hay un resumen de la lección, que trata sobre un modelo específico
de computación conocido como el modelo de consulta.
Puedes pensar en este modelo como una especie de placa de Petri para desarrollar ideas algorítmicas, tanto cuánticas como clásicas.
No pretende ser un modelo práctico que describa los tipos
de problemas computacionales que encontramos en la vida real.
Nos alejaremos del modelo de consulta en lecciones posteriores de esta unidad y nos centraremos en cambio en modelos motivados por nociones
más prácticas de computación,
pero el modelo de consulta es un
muy buen punto de partida.
Es un modelo simple que nos permite explorar el
potencial de las computadoras cuánticas sin que se interpongan
muchos detalles técnicos,
y también nos permite aislar algunas de las
ideas realmente importantes detrás de la computación cuántica y cómo funciona.
La computación cuántica se desarrolló, de hecho, dentro de este modelo, y las ideas que se
desarrollaron dentro de él inspiraron muy directamente
importantes algoritmos cuánticos
como el algoritmo de Shor para la factorización.
En la primera sección de la lección, veremos específicamente qué es el modelo de consulta de computación,
y en la segunda, tercera
y cuarta secciones, discutiremos tres
algoritmos de consulta cuántica, a saber, el algoritmo de Deutsch,
el algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa
y el algoritmo de Simon, que revelan ventajas
cada vez más impresionantes
de las computadoras cuánticas
sobre las computadoras clásicas dentro del modelo de consulta de computación.
Para explicar el modelo de consulta de computación, comencemos primero con una abstracción
más estándar de la computación.
Aquí hay una imagen que
representa una computación en términos muy simples y básicos.
Tenemos una entrada, que generalmente toma la
forma de una cadena binaria, aunque podríamos usar otros
símbolos si quisiéramos.
La entrada se proporciona a la computación, que está representada por un
rectángulo azul en esta imagen,
y el resultado de la computación es que se produce alguna salida, y de nuevo, eso es
típicamente una cadena binaria.
Por supuesto, esta imagen
no es nada específica sobre cómo funciona la computación en sí.
Podemos formular diferentes
modelos computacionales específicos para hacer eso, como las máquinas de Turing
y los circuit Booleanos,
o los circuit cuánticos si estamos pensando en
computación cuántica.
Es cierto que esta imagen
no representa el hecho de que muchas de las
computadoras que usamos todos los días están recibiendo
continuamente entradas y produciendo salidas,
esencialmente interactuando con nosotros y con otras computadoras a través de
internet, por ejemplo.
Pero no estamos intentando representar
esas interacciones aquí.
Esto trata sobre el modelado de
tareas computacionales aisladas.
Por ejemplo, la entrada podría ser la
codificación binaria de un número o la representación de una matriz
o la descripción de una molécula o realmente cualquier otra cosa que tengamos en mente, y hay alguna tarea computacional
que se realiza únicamente sobre esa entrada.
El punto clave aquí es
que toda la entrada se le proporciona a la computación, y nada de la
entrada le está oculto.
El modelo de consulta de
computación funciona de manera diferente.
En el modelo de consulta, la entrada se pone a disposición
en forma de una función a la que la computación puede
acceder haciendo consultas,
o en otras palabras, evaluando la función
sobre diferentes entradas.
Aquí puedes ver eso representado
en forma de imagen.
Similar a lo que vimos antes, la computación está representada
por un rectángulo azul, pero en vez de recibir una entrada directamente
en forma de una cadena
de bits, por ejemplo, accede a la entrada haciendo efectivamente preguntas
y recibiendo respuestas.
A veces usamos los
términos oráculo y caja negra para referirnos al mecanismo
que proporciona la entrada.
Hay una distinción entre
un oráculo y una caja negra en la teoría de la complejidad, pero eso no será relevante en absoluto para los propósitos de esta discusión.
De todos modos, estos términos pretenden
transmitir la idea básica.
En la antigua Grecia, podías
ir a un oráculo, como el Oráculo de Delfos,
y hacer una pregunta importante,
y el oráculo respondía
esa pregunta específica, pero desde luego no te contaba todo lo que sabía.
En la misma línea, cuando
pensamos en una caja negra, tenemos en mente algún
tipo de proceso o sistema
donde podemos elegir qué entra y podemos ver qué sale, pero no tenemos ningún conocimiento
de su funcionamiento interno.
Y ese es el caso aquí. La entrada al problema
toma la forma de una función, y todo lo que podemos hacer es
evaluar esa función,
pero, por lo demás, no tenemos
ningún conocimiento ni comprensión de cómo funciona.
A lo largo de la lección,
reservaremos la letra f para la función que
representa la entrada, y haremos la suposición
de que siempre toma la
forma que ves aquí.
Sigma denota el alfabeto binario, así que f es una función de cadenas
de bits a cadenas de bits,
y específicamente, vamos a
suponer que la entrada de f es una cadena de bits de longitud n, y la salida es una cadena
de bits de longitud m,
donde n y m son enteros positivos.
Para distintos problemas, tendremos
restricciones sobre n y m, pero en todos los casos, la función de entrada tomará
una forma como esta.
Cuando decimos que una
computación hace una consulta, lo que queremos decir es que la
función f se evalúa una vez,
es decir, la computación selecciona alguna cadena x de longitud N, y luego la cadena f de x se
pone a su disposición
por el oráculo o la caja negra. Y por último, la forma muy sencilla en que mediremos el costo computacional
de un algoritmo de consulta es contar cuántas consultas requiere.
Así que, aunque es verdad que
nos interesa principalmente cuánto tardan las computaciones, cuando estudiamos el modelo de consulta,
generalmente simplificamos las cosas
y solo contamos las consultas, y eso es lo que haremos en esta lección.
Ahora, veamos algunos
ejemplos de problemas de consulta, es decir, problemas computacionales en el modelo de consulta,
y aquí, por cierto, solo voy a describir
los problemas en sí mismos, y en este punto no diré nada
sobre cómo resolverlos.
El primer problema es el problema OR.
En este caso, la entrada es una función
de n bits a solo 1 bit, así que m es igual a 1 para este problema,
y la salida requerida para
el problema es 1 o 0.
Si existe alguna cadena de n bits x para la cual f de x es igual a 1, entonces la respuesta correcta es 1,
y en caso contrario, si f de x es
siempre 0 para toda cadena x, entonces la respuesta correcta es 0.
Entonces, si pensamos en la función f como dándonos acceso aleatorio a dos elevado a n bits, uno para cada cadena x de n bits,
entonces lo que se pide
es el OR de esos bits, y por eso se llama el problema OR.
Otro ejemplo es el problema de la paridad, que es similar al problema OR excepto que pide la paridad,
o en otras palabras, el OR exclusivo de todos los valores
de salida de un solo bit de la función.
Otra forma de decirlo es
que la respuesta correcta es 0 si el número de cadenas de n bits x para las cuales f de x es igual a 1 es par,
y la respuesta correcta es
1 si ese número es impar.
Un ejemplo de un problema donde m no es necesariamente igual a 1 es el problema del mínimo.
Aquí, la función f toma la forma habitual, y no hay restricciones sobre n y m,
y la respuesta correcta es cualquier valor de salida
de la función que aparezca primero en el orden
lexicográfico o de diccionario
de cadenas binarias. Alternativamente, si quieres
pensar en cadenas de longitud m como representando enteros no negativos
en notación binaria,
entonces la respuesta correcta
es el valor mínimo o más pequeño posible que
produce esta función.
A veces también consideramos problemas de consulta donde tenemos una promesa
sobre la función de entrada, o en otras palabras, algún
tipo de garantía sobre ella,
y no nos preocupamos por las funciones que no cumplen esa promesa.
Las funciones que no satisfacen la promesa se consideran entradas "no importa".
Y simplemente no somos responsables de lo que ocurre con esas entradas.
Aquí hay un ejemplo de un problema de consulta con una promesa llamada búsqueda única.
Está relacionado con el problema
OR, pero es diferente.
La función de entrada tiene la misma
forma que en el problema OR, es decir, toma
cadenas de n bits a bits.
Esta vez, se nos promete que
hay exactamente una cadena Z que hace que f evalúe a 1,
con f de x igual a 0
para toda cadena x distinta de z, y la salida correcta
es esta cadena única z.
Por supuesto, hay
opciones para la función f que no satisfacen esta condición, pero no imponemos ningún requisito en absoluto
sobre los algoritmos para este problema cuando se les dan esas
funciones como entrada.
Solo nos importan las funciones que sí satisfacen la promesa.
Ahora bien, los cuatro
problemas que acabo de mencionar son bastante naturales, en el sentido de que es fácil explicarlos,
y es fácil imaginar situaciones en las que podría surgir la necesidad de resolverlos, pero algunos problemas de consulta
no son así para nada.
De hecho, a veces consideramos problemas de consulta muy
artificiales, donde es difícil imaginar que alguien alguna vez
quisiera resolverlos realmente.
El problema de Simon, que veremos
más adelante en la lección, cae un poco en esta categoría, pero hay otros
que son mucho peores en cierto sentido, pero que, sin embargo, resultan ser bastante importantes para el estudio del modelo de consulta.
No estudiamos estos problemas porque necesariamente queramos
resolverlos en la práctica.
La forma de verlo es que estamos buscando
extremos de distintos tipos,
en particular, cuando trabajamos dentro de
este modelo como si fuera una placa de Petri, una forma natural de explorar
ideas algorítmicas cuánticas
es formular problemas muy artificiales, donde podemos aprovechar mejor el
poder de las computadoras cuánticas.
Y esto puede
arrojar mucha luz sobre cómo las computadoras cuánticas
pueden ser potencialmente útiles en entornos más prácticos.
Podemos formalizar la noción
de consulta de distintas formas según el modelo computacional
con el que estemos trabajando.
Por ejemplo, en el modelo de
máquina de Turing, del que no hemos hablado y no entraremos en detalle en esta serie,
hay una cierta forma de
formalizar la noción de consulta que tiene sentido para ese modelo.
Para los modelos de circuit, definimos tipos especiales de
gates llamados query gates, y así es como se representan formalmente las consultas.
Para los circuitos booleanos, hay una forma muy sencilla de hacer esto, que es simplemente imaginar
que tenemos query gates
que evalúan la función de entrada directamente, como puedes ver aquí en pantalla.
La idea es que podemos
usar estos query gates para construir circuits que resuelvan el
problema que estemos analizando,
y para funcionar correctamente, los circuits deben dar la respuesta correcta para cualquier función de entrada f que se les dé,
asumiendo que cumple la promesa en el caso de un problema con promesa.
Aquí hay un ejemplo sencillo
de un circuit booleano que resuelve el problema de paridad
cuando n es igual a 1,
por lo que la función de entrada f va
de 1 bit a 1 bit en este caso.
Lo que hace este circuit es evaluar la función
f en las entradas 0 y 1 usando estos dos query gates.
Luego toma los dos valores de salida que obtiene de los query gates y los introduce en el circuit booleano de la lección tres que calcula el XOR,
que es lo mismo que la paridad.
Para que quede claro, estos dos
valores de entrada aquí no son entradas al problema,
es decir, al problema de paridad,
cuando trabajamos con el modelo de consulta, la entrada al problema
es la función f, y debes pensar en estas
dos entradas al circuit
como valores fijos
que nunca cambian; son esencialmente parte del algoritmo.
Queremos calcular el XOR de f 0 y f 1, así que inicializamos estos
dos cables de esta manera
para que funcione. Hemos usado dos query gates
aquí, este y este,
y por tanto el algoritmo representado
por este circuit booleano hace dos consultas, y si pensamos en el
problema de paridad por un momento
para funciones de un bit a un bit, vemos que es absolutamente necesario para cualquier circuit booleano
que resuelva este problema
hacer al menos dos consultas.
Si solo haces una consulta, de modo que solo conoces un
valor de salida de la función f y no el otro, en realidad no tienes
ninguna información en absoluto
sobre la paridad, porque el otro valor de salida
podría ser igualmente 0 o 1, dando lugar a cualquiera de las
dos soluciones posibles
al problema. Así que en términos del número
de consultas que hace, este circuit booleano es lo mejor que se puede lograr
para el problema de paridad
cuando n es igual a 1.
Hay otro punto sobre los query gates que vale la pena mencionar antes de continuar, y es que cuando diseñamos y analizamos algoritmos de consulta,
no nos preocupamos en absoluto por cómo
se implementan los query gates.
Se asume que estos
query gates nos son dados, y la dificultad de construirlos
no es nuestra preocupación.
Puedes pensar en los
query gates en sí mismos como la entrada si quieres, y no es nuestro trabajo crear la entrada, solo estamos intentando
resolver un problema concreto
dada la entrada. Por supuesto, cuando f es una función
de un bit a un bit, solo hay cuatro posibles opciones,
y sería bastante fácil
implementar cualquiera de ellas, pero en general, para funciones
con muchos bits de entrada,
podría ser extremadamente difícil implementar query gates
para esas funciones.
Para ser claros, esto no significa
que la cuestión de cómo se implementan los query gates
no sea importante, sino que no se considera
parte del costo
de un algoritmo de consulta.
Esto es coherente con la idea de que esto no se trata realmente
de computación práctica ni de construir circuits como tal,
sino de trabajar dentro de
un marco teórico que nos dice cosas interesantes
sobre la computación.
Tendremos más que decir sobre esto cuando hagamos el salto de este modelo a un modelo más estándar de computación, y de eso trata principalmente la próxima lección,
la Lección 6.
Ahora centrémonos
en los quantum circuits.
Para los quantum circuits, vamos a cambiar la
definición de query gates para hacerlos unitarios.
Queremos poder hacer
consultas dentro de quantum circuits y que operen
linealmente sobre estados cuánticos
para poder hacer consultas
en superposición de forma efectiva.
Puede parecer que estamos
moviendo el listón, por así decirlo, al cambiar lo que entendemos por consulta en comparación con lo que acabamos
de ver para los Boolean circuits,
pero hay una justificación para ello que discutiremos con más
detalle en la próxima lección.
Por ahora, es solo una definición.
En concreto, la
definición es la siguiente: dada cualquier función f de
la misma forma que antes,
es decir, que mapea cadenas de n bits
a cadenas de m bits, el query gate Uf actúa sobre n + m qubits
y se define por la
acción descrita aquí sobre estados de la base estándar.
Veremos una figura
que representa esta definición en un momento, pero primero déjame aclarar la notación
que se usa aquí,
y es que cuando usamos
el símbolo de la XOR como operación entre dos
cadenas de igual longitud,
nos referimos al
OR exclusivo bit a bit, y aquí puedes ver un ejemplo.
En la definición, tenemos que tanto y como f de
x son cadenas de longitud m, así que esta cadena de aquí
representa la cadena que obtenemos
al aplicar la XOR a esas dos cadenas
bit a bit, y aquí está el diagrama
que explica cómo funcionan estos gates.
Los n qubits superiores corresponden al
argumento de la función.
Y cuando empiezan
en un estado de la base estándar, ket x en este diagrama, ese estado de la base estándar
pasa sin cambios
y se reproduce como parte de la salida.
Los m qubits inferiores corresponden a la salida
de la función f, y cuando empiezan en
cualquier estado de la base estándar,
ket y en este diagrama, lo que ocurre es que la
salida de la función f de x se aplica con XOR sobre la cadena y.
Esto es lo que ocurre con
los estados de la base estándar, y si queremos saber
qué ocurre en general para otros estados cuánticos,
usamos la linealidad, como siempre.
Una razón para definir los query gates así, donde reproducimos la entrada y usamos la XOR bit a bit para la salida,
es que estos gates son siempre unitarios para cualquier elección de la función f.
Esta es, de hecho, una
operación determinista.
Y si lo expresáramos como una matriz para cualquier elección de una función F, obtendríamos una matriz de permutación,
es decir, una con un único uno en cada fila y en cada columna, y todas las demás entradas iguales a 0.
Y las matrices de permutación
son siempre unitarias.
De hecho, para esta operación,
obtendremos que la operación es su propia inversa, es decir, Uf dagger es igual a Uf.
Si todo lo que queremos hacer con estos
gates es evaluar f de x para alguna cadena x, eso es fácil,
podemos simplemente fijar y como
la cadena de todos ceros. Así, cuando calculamos la OR exclusiva bit a bit de y, obtenemos simplemente f de x.
Aquí, por cierto, puedes ver la notación que se usa para denotar la cadena de todos ceros.
Parece 0 elevado a la potencia M, pero eso no es lo que significa.
Significa la cadena de ceros
de longitud igual a M.
Cuando hablamos de
cadenas en vez de números, los exponentes típicamente significan que repetimos esa cadena
un cierto número de veces,
así que esto es 0 repetido m veces.
Es simplemente una forma conveniente y precisa de describir esta cadena.
Una vez más, cuando trabajamos
con el modelo de consulta, no nos preocupamos de cómo
implementar estos query gates.
Ese es el mismo problema
que teníamos con los query gates para Boolean circuits.
No es nuestro trabajo preparar la entrada; se nos da la entrada en forma
de estos query gates.
Cabe señalar, sin embargo, que si sabemos cómo
implementar la función f usando un Boolean circuit, entonces es posible
traducir esa implementación
de manera bastante directa a una implementación en un quantum
circuit de Uf, y veremos exactamente cómo
funciona eso en la próxima lección.
Como nota aparte, es bastante sencillo crear un Boolean circuit
que funcione así, usando un único query gate
clásico para la función f,
pero eso es muy diferente a tener una implementación en un quantum
circuit de este gate unitario.
El punto, sin embargo, es que
para los algoritmos de consulta clásicos, tener un query gate que funcione así es, de hecho, equivalente
a tener un query gate
clásico ordinario para f, en el sentido de que cualquiera de los dos puede implementarse usando el otro.
En esta sección de la lección, hablaremos del algoritmo de Deutsch, que es un
quantum query algorithm muy simple, pero realmente es una joya.
Este algoritmo proviene de un artículo de 1985 escrito por David Deutsch, quien fue una de las primeras personas en trabajar en los fundamentos
teóricos de la computación cuántica.
El algoritmo en sí representa una parte muy pequeña
del artículo de Deutsch de 1985 y, de hecho,
el algoritmo que hoy
llamamos algoritmo de Deutsch es en realidad una versión mejorada del algoritmo que Deutsch describió.
Ofrece un ejemplo muy modesto de cómo las computadoras cuánticas pueden
brindar ventajas computacionales, pero hay que empezar por algún lado,
y realmente fue una chispa importante que puso las cosas en marcha.
El algoritmo de Deutsch resuelve un problema de consulta que suele llamarse el problema de Deutsch en el contexto de la computación cuántica,
pero en realidad no es otro que
el problema de paridad para funciones de un bit a un bit, del que ya hemos hablado.
Como ya hemos visto, hay cuatro funciones
de un bit a un bit, y aquí en pantalla se describen mediante sus tablas de valores.
La primera y la última de estas
funciones son constantes, mientras que las dos del medio son balanceadas en el sentido de que los dos
posibles valores de salida
aparecen el mismo número de veces.
Para las dos funciones constantes,
vemos que la paridad, o en otras palabras, el OR exclusivo de las dos salidas es 0,
y para las dos funciones balanceadas, la paridad de las salidas es 1.
Entonces, una forma equivalente de
describir el problema de paridad en este caso particular, donde la función f toma
un único bit como entrada,
o en otras palabras, el problema de Deutsch, es como ves aquí.
La entrada es una función f
de un bit a un bit, y la salida es 0 si f es constante
y 1 si f es balanceada.
Como ya sugerí, todo algoritmo de consulta clásico
que resuelva este problema debe hacer al menos dos consultas a f.
Si conoces solo uno de
los dos valores de salida de f, todavía no tienes ninguna información sobre la paridad de las dos salidas.
Y esto, por cierto, es verdad
incluso para algoritmos clásicos que usan aleatoriedad.
La aleatoriedad a veces puede ser muy útil para resolver problemas de consulta, y veremos un ejemplo
un poco más adelante en la lección,
pero la aleatoriedad no ayuda aquí.
Entonces, nuestro algoritmo anterior es óptimo entre los algoritmos de consulta clásicos
para el problema de Deutsch.
Ahora vamos a echar un vistazo
al algoritmo de Deutsch, que es un quantum query algorithm que resuelve el problema de Deutsch
usando una sola consulta.
Y aquí está el algoritmo
descrito como un quantum circuit.
Tenemos dos qubits
inicializados como ves aquí, con el de arriba inicializado a ket 0 y el de abajo inicializado a ket 1,
y veremos por qué inicializamos estos qubits así en un momento.
Aplicamos Hadamard
gates a los dos qubits, los pasamos por el query gate, aplicamos otro Hadamard
gate al qubit de arriba,
y luego lo medimos. Y la afirmación es que
el resultado de la medición nos da, con certeza, la
respuesta correcta al problema.
Así que analicemos el
circuit paso a paso para ver exactamente cómo funciona.
El estado de los dos qubits después de la primera capa de Hadamard gates es el producto tensorial de
los estados menos y más.
El Hadamard de arriba transforma
el estado 0 en un estado más, y el Hadamard de abajo transforma el estado 1 en un estado menos.
El qubit de arriba está a la derecha y el qubit de abajo está a la izquierda, así que este es el estado que obtenemos.
Es muy importante que el qubit de abajo esté en un estado menos; esto no funcionaría si
inicializamos el qubit de abajo
en un estado 0 en lugar de un estado 1.
Vamos a expandir este estado
a medias, como ves aquí.
La razón para hacer eso
no queda clara en este momento, pero será conveniente
en un instante.
A continuación, pensemos en
el estado de los dos qubits después de que se aplica el query gate.
La forma en que funciona el query gate
es que calcula F sobre el estado de la base estándar
del qubit de arriba y aplica XOR con ese valor
al qubit de abajo,
y aquí podemos ver el
resultado de hacer eso.
Para el primer término, el estado de la base estándar
del qubit de arriba es 0, así que f de cero se aplica con XOR
al qubit de abajo,
y eso funciona por linealidad. Y es similar para el segundo término, excepto que el estado de la base estándar
para el qubit superior es 1, así que aplicamos XOR de f de 1 al qubit inferior.
Y en este punto, podemos
simplificar esta expresión observando la fórmula
que puedes ver aquí abajo, que funciona cuando a es 0 o 1.
Y simplemente podemos verificar esto para esos dos valores por separado.
Si a es igual a 0, entonces
aplicar XOR con a no hace nada, y negativo 1 elevado a la potencia 0 es 1,
por lo que los dos lados son iguales. Y si a es igual a 1, obtenemos cat 1 menos cat
0 cuando aplicamos el XOR,
que es negativo 1
por cat 0 menos cat 1.
Y si usamos esa fórmula
para simplificar nuestro estado, donde tomamos a igual
a f de 0 a la izquierda y a igual a f de 1 a la derecha,
obtenemos la expresión
que puedes ver aquí mismo.
Entonces, cuando comparamos los dos
vectores de estado cuántico π1 y π2, vemos que lo que hace el gate Uf
es efectivamente colocar
uno de los dos valores, f de 0 o f de 1, en el
exponente de negativo 1,
o en otras palabras, en
la fase de cada término.
Esta es la razón por la que
inicializamos el qubit inferior a 1 y le aplicamos un Hadamard gate para crear el estado menos,
lo cual permite que esto ocurra.
Se llama el fenómeno de phase kickback, y volveremos a él en unos momentos para observarlo desde otro ángulo.
Es bastante importante, y lo veremos ocurrir
algunas veces más en esta lección, así como en lecciones posteriores.
Ahora podemos simplificar sacando
el estado menos hacia afuera para obtener la expresión
que puedes ver aquí mismo.
A modo de observación, es bastante
interesante notar que en realidad no hay
ningún entrelazamiento aquí.
Ambos estados son estados producto. Así que, bueno, el entrelazamiento
es extremadamente interesante,
pero no ocurre que
desempeñe ningún papel en este algoritmo en particular.
Limpiemos esto un poco para tener algo más de espacio.
Lo que podemos hacer ahora es
sacar un factor de negativo 1 elevado a la potencia f de cero hacia afuera
para obtener la expresión del
estado que puedes ver aquí mismo.
Notarás que aquí tenemos el XOR de f de 0 y f de 1 en el exponente de negativo 1.
Podríamos esperar que sea
f de 1 menos f de 0 porque sacamos el factor de negativo 1 a la potencia f de 0,
pero obtenemos el mismo
valor si tomamos el XOR porque estos son bits, y lo único que importa cuando tenemos un entero en
el exponente de negativo 1
es si ese entero es par o impar.
Otra forma de expresar este
estado es como la que tenemos aquí, donde simplemente estamos considerando
los dos casos posibles para el XOR.
y esa es una forma conveniente
de expresar el estado mientras consideramos la acción
del Hadamard gate final junto con la medición.
Cuando aplicamos el último
Hadamard gate al qubit superior, el estado más se
transforma en el estado 0
y el estado menos se
transforma en el estado 1, lo que podemos escribir de forma
más concisa así.
Y finalmente, cuando se
realiza la medición, el resultado que obtenemos es
por lo tanto el XOR de f de 0 y f de 1,
que es el valor que buscamos, y así es como funciona el algoritmo de Deutsch.
Es bastante simple, y si nos preguntamos qué
es lo que lo hace funcionar, permitiéndonos calcular
la paridad de dos bits
con una sola consulta en lugar de dos, una respuesta razonable es
que es la interferencia.
Efectivamente estamos
calculando f de 0 y f de 1 al mismo tiempo, porque primero aplicamos
el Hadamard gate
al qubit superior para poner la entrada de f en
una superposición de 0 y 1.
Y mediante el phase kickback junto con el Hadamard gate final, estamos esencialmente creando
interferencia constructiva
para la respuesta correcta e interferencia destructiva
para la respuesta incorrecta.
Así que no vemos la respuesta incorrecta, solo vemos la respuesta correcta.
Déjame decir un poco más sobre el fenómeno del phase kickback solo para verlo desde un
ángulo ligeramente diferente.
Primero, observemos
esta fórmula muy simple donde b y c son valores binarios arbitrarios.
En resumen, aplicar XOR a un bit b con el valor 1 es lo mismo que aplicar un gate NOT o una operación x a b,
y por supuesto, aplicar XOR
a un bit b con el valor 0 no le hace nada, lo que equivale a aplicarle la
operación identidad.
Y podemos expresar la operación identidad como x elevado a la potencia 0.
Así que si aplicamos un Uf gate a dos qubits en el estado de la base estándar cat b tensor cat a,
obtenemos este resultado, simplemente por la definición del Uf gate.
y usando la fórmula, podemos escribir ese estado de manera alternativa como puedes ver aquí mismo.
Esta fórmula funciona para todas las elecciones de b, por lo que por linealidad, funciona
para un estado arbitrario SI
en lugar de cat b.
Y en particular, si queremos, podemos elegir SI como el estado menos.
Y aquí está la clave de por qué ocurre el fenómeno
de phase kickback.
Es porque la operación x
aplicada al estado menos nos da negativo 1 por el estado menos.
En términos matemáticos, decimos que el estado
menos es un eigenvector de la operación x, con eigenvalor igual a negativo 1.
Los eigenvectors y eigenvalores
son de suma importancia tanto en álgebra lineal como
en información cuántica, y tendremos mucho
más que decir sobre ellos
a medida que la serie continúe.
Pero por ahora, todo lo que necesitamos
es esta fórmula sencilla.
Y usándola, podemos
simplificar nuestro vector de estado.
Y eso que ves ahí es esencialmente el fenómeno
de phase kickback escrito como una fórmula.
Funciona porque el estado
menos es un eigenvector de la operación NOT con
eigenvalor negativo uno.
Generalizaremos esto de una manera
bastante importante en la Lección 7, cuando pasemos al procedimiento de
estimación de fase, que es lo que impulsa
el algoritmo de factorización de Shor.
Podemos ver esta fórmula en acción en el análisis del algoritmo
de Deutsch de la siguiente manera.
Antes del query gate, nuestro estado es el producto tensorial de los estados menos y más.
Luego aplicamos el query gate, y al expandir el estado
más obtenemos este estado.
Ahora aplicamos la fórmula de phase kickback para obtener esta expresión, y entonces el análisis
continúa como antes.
Es igual que antes, pero aquí simplemente estamos poniendo
el foco en el phase kickback para poder reconocerlo
y también estar preparados para
cuando vuelva a aparecer.
A continuación, pasaremos al
algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa, que es una extensión
del algoritmo de Deutsch que en realidad resuelve un par
de problemas de consulta distintos.
La ventaja que
el algoritmo de Deutsch ofrece sobre los algoritmos clásicos
es bastante modesta: una consulta frente a dos.
El algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa aumenta esa ventaja en cierta medida, y explicaré qué quiero decir
con eso cuando lleguemos ahí.
El algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa puede verse como una forma natural y directa de extender el algoritmo de Deutsch
de funciones de un bit a un bit a funciones de n bits a un bit, o en otras palabras, funciones de esta forma.
Como circuit cuántico, el algoritmo de
Deutsch-Jozsa se ve así, y voy a referirme a esto
como el circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa
solo para marcar una pequeña
distinción entre este circuit y el propio algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa, porque también hay un
paso de posprocesamiento clásico.
La idea es que si ejecutamos
este circuit y luego medimos, obtendremos alguna cadena de n bits y
que nos dice algo
sobre la función f.
A estas alturas, por cierto, en realidad no he dicho
cuál es el problema de consulta que esperamos
resolver con este circuit; eso viene muy pronto.
Pero la cuestión es que
al ejecutar este circuit, obtendremos cierta información sobre f que potencialmente puede ayudarnos
a resolver problemas de consulta
donde f es la entrada. Y como dije hace un momento, en realidad podemos usar este circuit
para resolver un par de
problemas de consulta distintos.
Primero, veamos
el problema de consulta conocido como el problema de Deutsch-Jozsa, que es el problema que
el circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa
fue diseñado originalmente para resolver.
El problema de Deutsch-Jozsa es una generalización del problema de Deutsch, donde el objetivo es determinar si una función dada
es constante o balanceada.
Nota que esta no es la forma natural de generalizar el problema de la paridad
a funciones de esta forma.
Aquí no estamos calculando la paridad; la tarea es devolver 0 si
la función f es constante
y 1 si la función f es balanceada.
Lo primero que hay que notar sobre
este problema es que cuando n, el número de bits de entrada de
la función f, es al menos 2,
hay funciones que no son ni constantes ni balanceadas.
Por ejemplo, aquí hay una
función de 2 bits a 1 bit que no es ni constante ni balanceada.
No es constante porque ambos valores binarios
aparecen entre las salidas, y no es balanceada
porque los dos valores de salida
aparecen con frecuencias distintas. El 0 aparece tres veces
y el 1 aparece solo una vez.
Para que sea balanceada,
las salidas 0 y 1 tienen que ocurrir exactamente
el mismo número de veces.
El hecho de que existan funciones que no son ni constantes ni balanceadas cuando n es al menos 2 no es un problema; simplemente vamos a considerar
funciones así
como entradas "don't care". Así que, en otras palabras, esto
es un problema de promesa.
Y aquí hay un enunciado
preciso del problema.
Se nos promete que la función de entrada f es constante o balanceada, y el objetivo es determinar
cuál de las dos es.
Y no somos responsables de lo que ocurra si la entrada
no cumple la promesa.
El algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa,
que resuelve este problema, consiste primero en ejecutar el circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa y luego devolver 0
si la cadena que
obtenemos de las mediciones es la cadena de todos ceros,
y devolver 1 en caso contrario.
Otra forma de decirlo es que generamos el OR de
los bits que medimos.
Para analizar el algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa, será útil
tomarnos unos momentos para pensar en los Hadamard gates.
Por supuesto, podemos describir la operación
Hadamard como una matriz, pero también podemos describirla
en términos de su acción
sobre los estados de la base estándar,
como ves aquí mismo.
Estas dos ecuaciones se pueden
combinar en una sola ecuación, que describe cómo funciona
una operación Hadamard cuando a es cualquiera de
los dos valores binarios,
y podemos ir un poco más allá y expresar lo que
obtenemos como una suma así.
Usando esa fórmula, podemos derivar una fórmula que describe cómo funciona una capa
de Hadamard gates, en la que aplicamos un Hadamard
gate a cada uno de los n qubits.
Aquí describimos esta
acción sobre los estados de la base estándar.
Y para ser claros con la notación, cuando escribimos h tensorial n así, donde la parte tensorial n es un superíndice,
lo que queremos decir es el producto tensorial
de orden n de H consigo mismo, o en otras palabras, n copias
de h todas tensoradas juntas.
Estamos aplicando esta operación
a un estado de la base estándar, y aquí sigo la
convención que usa Qiskit
para indexar cadenas binarias, simplemente porque es
un buen momento para presentar esa convención.
Así que x0 es un bit, x1 es un bit,
y así sucesivamente con n bits en total, y los bits están ordenados como
ves aquí en la pantalla.
Puedes pensar en esta
forma de indexar los bits como si correspondiera a su significancia si consideramos las cadenas como
representaciones de enteros
en notación binaria, por ejemplo.
Si aplicamos un Hadamard gate
a cada uno de estos qubits, podemos expresar el resultado alternativamente como el producto tensorial de orden n
de un Hadamard gate aplicado a cada qubit, y luego podemos aplicar nuestra fórmula a cada uno de los factores tensoriales.
Y aquí usamos los
nombres y con índice n menos 1 hasta y1 en lugar de b en la fórmula,
así que estos son valores binarios. Y nos aseguramos de usar un nombre nuevo cada vez que aplicamos la fórmula.
Si luego expandimos todo usando la multilinealidad
de los productos tensoriales, obtenemos la expresión
que ves aquí mismo.
Y para ser claros, las n sumas se están
combinando en una sola suma, pero seguimos sumando
sobre todos los valores posibles
de los valores binarios individuales.
Ahora simplifiquemos las cosas para poder ir un poco más allá.
El siguiente paso es
introducir una nueva operación sobre cadenas llamada producto punto binario.
Es una operación sobre cadenas binarias de la misma longitud.
Y lo que es el producto punto binario de dos cadenas x e y
de la misma longitud es el OR exclusivo, o la paridad,
de los productos de los bits individuales.
También podrías decir que es el XOR del AND lógico de los bits individuales, porque el AND es lo
mismo que el producto
para valores binarios. Otra forma más de describirlo
es que vale 1 o 0
dependiendo de si
la suma de los productos de los bits individuales es impar o par.
Es muy similar a un producto interior si pensamos en las cadenas
como vectores de valores binarios, pero donde calculamos Módulo-2,
o en otras palabras, tomamos el resto al dividir por 2.
Aunque en realidad no es un producto interior, así que merece un nombre distinto.
En el caso que nos ocupa, podemos usar el producto punto
binario para hacer más concisa nuestra fórmula para la acción de una capa de Hadamard gates
sobre los estados de la base estándar, y aquí está.
Usamos el hecho de que,
como esta suma aparece en el
exponente de menos 1,
lo único que importa es si
es par o impar, pero por lo demás, es básicamente solo una versión condensada
de nuestra fórmula.
Por cierto, el producto punto binario
es simétrico en el sentido de que x punto
y e y punto x son iguales,
así que podemos intercambiar el
orden cuando nos resulte conveniente.
Y ahora que tenemos esa fórmula, será bastante fácil analizar
el circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa.
Empezamos con n qubits en el estado 0 y el qubit inferior en el estado 1, y aplicamos Hadamard
gates a todos ellos.
Este es el estado de los
n + 1 qubits que obtenemos.
Tratamos el
qubit inferior por separado porque eso nos va a resultar conveniente.
Y de nuevo, vamos a ver el fenómeno de
phase kickback ocurriendo.
Podemos obtener esta expresión
usando nuestra fórmula, donde sustituimos la
cadena de todos ceros por x y sustituimos x por y,
teniendo en cuenta que el producto punto
binario de la cadena de todos ceros con cualquier cadena es 0.
Pero también podemos razonarlo directamente. Estamos tomando el producto tensorial de n estados más, y esto es lo que obtenemos,
tensorial con el estado menos. Luego se aplica el gate UF, y aquí es donde ocurre el fenómeno de
phase kickback.
El valor f de x se está aplicando
con XOR al estado menos para cada x en la suma.
Entonces f de x pasa a la fase.
Ahora aplicamos otra
capa de Hadamard gates solo a los n qubits superiores, y esta vez sí
necesitamos la fórmula.
Y cuando la aplicamos y hacemos solo un poco
de simplificación, obtenemos este estado aquí.
Así que ese es nuestro estado final justo
antes de las mediciones.
El estado parece un poco complicado, y es difícil simplificarlo porque realmente no sabemos
nada sobre la función f.
Pero recuerda que todo
lo que realmente necesitamos saber es si las mediciones
producen o no el resultado 0,
porque eso es lo que determina cuál es nuestra respuesta al problema.
Si vemos que todos
los resultados de las mediciones son 0, concluimos que la función es constante.
Y si alguno de los
resultados de las mediciones es 1, concluimos que la función es balanceada.
Así que calculemos la probabilidad de obtener la cadena de todos ceros
a partir de las mediciones.
Y resulta que ese es el único resultado que es fácil de calcular, porque el producto punto binario
de la cadena de todos ceros
con cualquier cadena es cero. Si examinamos nuestro vector y
pensamos en qué pasa cuando y es la cadena de todos ceros,
obtenemos esta expresión aquí
para la probabilidad de obtener la cadena de todos ceros
a partir de las mediciones.
Y considerando los dos casos posibles donde f es constante y f es balanceada, vemos que la probabilidad de
obtener la cadena de todos ceros es 1
en el caso de que f sea constante, y cero cuando f es balanceada.
Cuando f es constante, la suma es 2 elevado a la
n o negativo 2 elevado a la n, y al dividir entre dos elevado a la n
y tomar el valor absoluto
al cuadrado obtenemos 1.
Y cuando f es balanceada, la suma es igual a 0.
Eso se debe a que obtendremos
1 positivo y 1 negativo un número igual de veces,
así que todos se cancelan.
Y eso es todo. El algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa
resuelve el problema de Deutsch-Jozsa usando una sola consulta,
y no hay error. Suponiendo que las operaciones
se realizan todas perfectamente, es correcto cada vez.
¿Cómo se compara eso con
lo que podemos hacer de forma clásica?
Bueno, si insistimos en un
algoritmo determinista que obtenga la respuesta
correcta cada vez, entonces en el peor caso,
necesitamos 2 elevado a la n menos 1 más 1 consultas, y eso se debe a que tenemos
que consultar la función
en más de la mitad de sus entradas para estar seguros sobre la solución.
Incluso si consultamos la función en 2 elevado a la n menos 1
cadenas de entrada distintas, es posible que veamos el mismo valor de salida
cada vez, y podría ser porque
la función es constante, o podría ser que en realidad sea balanceada
y hemos tenido una mala suerte increíble al ver el mismo valor de salida
cada vez.
Así que esa es una gran ventaja
de lo cuántico sobre lo clásico: una sola consulta frente a
un número exponencial de consultas.
Sin embargo, si usamos un
algoritmo de consulta probabilístico y aceptamos una pequeña probabilidad de que responda incorrectamente,
entonces en realidad solo necesitamos unas pocas consultas.
En particular, si
elegimos aleatoriamente k cadenas y evaluamos la función
en esas cadenas aleatorias,
entonces es bastante probable que podamos determinar la respuesta correcta.
Concretamente, respondemos 0 o constante cuando obtenemos el mismo valor de la función
cada vez, y 1 o balanceada
cuando vemos dos
valores distintos de la función.
Si hacemos eso, siempre estaremos en lo correcto cuando
la función es constante porque, por supuesto, siempre veremos el mismo
valor de salida en este caso.
Y si f es balanceada, es muy probable que veamos
dos valores de salida distintos.
La probabilidad de no ver
ambos valores de salida en este caso es la misma que la probabilidad de lanzar una moneda k veces
y obtener el mismo
resultado cada vez.
Así que, por ejemplo, si
establecemos k igual a 11, la probabilidad de obtener una respuesta incorrecta es menor al décimo de un porcentaje.
Así que especialmente cuando consideramos el hecho de que los computadores cuánticos nunca van a ser perfectos en la realidad, en realidad no obtenemos una ventaja
tan grande aquí,
pero estamos progresando, y sí tenemos una ventaja cuantificable de lo cuántico sobre lo clásico que va más allá del algoritmo de Deutsch.
También podemos usar el circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa para resolver un problema de consulta diferente conocido como el problema de Bernstein-Vazirani.
Aquí está el enunciado de ese problema. La entrada es una función
de n bits a 1 bit, igual que en el problema de Deutsch-Jozsa,
y de nuevo, es un problema de promesa.
Esta vez, la promesa es que existe alguna cadena de n bits s para la cual la función f
funciona como ves aquí,
donde la salida está dada
por el producto punto binario de la entrada con esta cadena s,
y el objetivo es simplemente
encontrar la cadena s. Así que podemos imaginar que la
cadena s está oculta en cierto sentido,
pero podemos aprender sobre ella
haciendo consultas a f, y nuestro objetivo es encontrar
esta cadena oculta.
Para ser claros, la mayoría de las funciones
no van a satisfacer esta promesa, pero como de costumbre, solo nos importan las
funciones de entrada que sí lo hacen.
Resulta que el circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa resuelve este problema
de forma inmediata.
Si lo ejecutamos para una
función como la que tenemos aquí, que satisface la
promesa para alguna cadena s, las mediciones revelarán la cadena s
sin necesidad de ningún post-procesamiento.
Así que veamos cómo funciona esto.
Ya hemos analizado
el circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa, así que en realidad podemos
saltarnos directamente al final.
Aquí está la expresión que teníamos
antes para el estado justo antes de las mediciones, y esa expresión era
válida para cualquier función f.
Y ahora, si sustituimos
lo que nos prometen sobre la función f y simplificamos,
obtenemos el estado menos
para el qubit inferior en producto tensorial con cat s para los n qubits superiores.
Y así obtenemos s al medir.
Hay algo de trabajo que hacer para realizar las simplificaciones
que he mostrado aquí, y no lo voy a desarrollar en este video,
pero hay más detalles al respecto en el contenido del libro de texto de esta serie, que puedes encontrar siguiendo el enlace en la descripción del video,
o simplemente inténtalo tú mismo
como práctica.
Así que lo que encontramos es que
el circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa resuelve el problema de Bernstein-Vazirani
con una sola consulta.
No es muy difícil demostrar
que cualquier algoritmo clásico, ya sea determinista
o probabilístico, necesita al menos n consultas
para resolver el problema de Bernstein-Vazirani, por la sencilla razón de que necesitamos n bits de
información para recuperar s,
y cada consulta nos da como
mucho 1 bit de información.
Así que obtenemos otra ventaja cuántica sobre los algoritmos clásicos
de consulta: una consulta para los algoritmos cuánticos,
n consultas para los algoritmos clásicos.
Vale la pena detenerse un momento para hablar sobre la
nomenclatura que se usa en el contexto de este problema y un poco sobre la historia.
A veces la gente se refiere al algoritmo que acabo de describir como el algoritmo de Bernstein-Vazirani, pero en realidad es solo el
circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa,
y eso es algo que, de hecho,
quedó muy claramente establecido en el trabajo de Bernstein y Vazirani.
Así que es un poco extraño que se llame el
algoritmo de Bernstein-Vazirani porque es prácticamente lo mismo que el algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa
sin el post-procesamiento. Bernstein y Vazirani sí fueron,
sin embargo, un paso más allá.
Definieron una versión recursiva
de este problema, donde básicamente
hay que resolver instancias del problema de Bernstein-Vazirani
para desbloquear nuevas instancias del problema que están organizadas en un
complicado patrón de árbol.
Es un problema muy artificial, pero la cuestión es que al
definir un problema de esta manera, podían estirar efectivamente
la separación de una versus n consultas entre lo cuántico y lo clásico.
Y lo que obtuvieron es
el primer ejemplo conocido de una ventaja cuántica llamada superpolinomial sobre los algoritmos probabilísticos clásicos.
Esta versión recursiva del problema de
Bernstein-Vazirani también resultó ser, mucho más tarde,
muy interesante en la teoría de la
complejidad computacional por razones distintas.
De todos modos, el punto es que
Bernstein y Vazirani ciertamente merecen reconocimiento por sus importantes contribuciones,
pero realmente no tiene
mucho sentido referirse a esto como el algoritmo de Bernstein-Vazirani; en esencia es simplemente el
algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa.
En la última parte de la lección, veremos uno
más de los algoritmos cuánticos de consulta, conocido como el algoritmo de Simon.
Verás una clara similitud
entre este algoritmo y el de Deutsch-Jozsa, pero es diferente y, lo que es más importante,
revela una ventaja mucho mayor de lo cuántico sobre los algoritmos clásicos
de consulta.
Específicamente, nos da una
ventaja exponencial demostrable de lo cuántico sobre los algoritmos clásicos, incluso los probabilísticos.
El problema que resuelve es un poco artificial, y es difícil imaginar una situación en la que resolver este
problema sea útil,
pero sí inspiró directamente
el descubrimiento de Peter Shor de un algoritmo cuántico
para la factorización de enteros,
y eso apoya con mucha fuerza
esta idea del modelo de consulta como una placa de Petri en la que las ideas
algorítmicas cuánticas pueden desarrollarse.
Empecemos con el problema de consulta que resuelve el algoritmo de Simon, el cual, como ya habrás adivinado,
se llama el problema de Simon.
Aquí está el enunciado del problema, y vamos a tener que desglosarlo para entender de qué trata todo esto.
Lo primero que hay que
notar es que esta vez, la función de entrada f mapea cadenas de n
bits a cadenas de m bits
donde m es algún entero positivo que en general no es igual a uno.
Es un problema de promesa. Y al igual que el problema de Bernstein-Vazirani, la promesa involucra alguna cadena s que podemos ver como una cadena oculta,
y también al igual que el
problema de Bernstein-Vazirani, el objetivo es
dar como salida esta cadena oculta s.
La promesa es esta vez
más complicada, así que vamos a descomponerla y
entender qué está diciendo.
Para empezar, leámosla. Dice que existe una cadena s de longitud igual a n
tal que se cumple una condición particular de "si"
y "solo si" para todas las elecciones de cadenas de n bits x e y.
Específicamente, debe
ser el caso que f de x es igual a f de y si y solo si se da una de
dos posibilidades.
La primera posibilidad es que x sea igual a y, y la segunda posibilidad es que al tomar el
OR exclusivo bit a bit de x
con la cadena oculta s, obtenemos Y.
Esto resulta ser una
promesa bastante estricta, en el sentido de que la mayoría de
las funciones no la cumplirán.
Solo funciones muy especiales
satisfacen esta condición.
Ahora, para entender mejor esta promesa y, por ende, el problema en sí, consideraremos dos casos principales.
El primer caso es que s
es la cadena de todos ceros.
En este caso, podemos simplificar el enunciado
de "si" y "solo si" de la promesa, porque el
OR exclusivo bit a bit de cualquier cadena x
con la cadena de todos ceros
es simplemente la cadena x.
Así que la condición se simplifica
a: f de x es igual a f de y si y solo si x es igual a y.
Y eso es solo otra manera de decir que f es una función inyectiva.
En otras palabras, la cadena f de x debe ser única
para cada posible cadena x.
Entonces, si f es una función inyectiva, la promesa se cumple efectivamente, específicamente para s siendo
la cadena de todos ceros,
y en ese caso, esa es
la salida correcta.
El segundo caso es que s
no es la cadena de todos ceros, y lo que esto implica es que la función f debe ser dos a uno.
Entonces, para cada cadena de entrada x, hay exactamente otra cadena a la que f mapea la misma
cadena a la que mapea x,
y además, esa otra cadena
debe ser la que obtenemos al tomar el
OR exclusivo bit a bit de x con s.
Otra manera de decirlo
es que toda cadena de n bits x tiene una pareja, y esa pareja es la cadena que obtenemos
al tomar el OR exclusivo bit a bit con s.
Dos parejas cualesquiera deben darnos
la misma cadena de salida si las introducimos en f, y ninguna otra cadena puede darnos
esa misma cadena de salida.
Por lo tanto, las cadenas que producen las parejas son necesariamente distintas.
Aquí hay un ejemplo de una función como esta, descrita por su tabla de valores.
Esta es una función
de 3 bits a 5 bits.
Si miramos esta tabla
de valores por un momento, encontramos que la promesa se
cumple para la cadena 011.
000 y 011 son parejas. Al aplicar XOR a cualquiera de ellas
con s, obtenemos la otra,
y toman el mismo valor de salida, que es 10011 en este caso particular, y ninguna otra cadena produce
esa misma cadena de salida.
001 y 010 son parejas porque al aplicar XOR a cualquiera
de ellas con s se obtiene la otra, y producen el mismo valor de salida,
que, de nuevo, no es producido
por ninguna otra cadena.
Y la situación es
similar para 100 y 111, así como para 101 y 110.
Entonces, si la entrada al
problema es esta función, la respuesta correcta es la cadena 011.
Como dije antes, la mayoría de las funciones no satisfacen esta promesa; es una condición muy específica.
También hay que señalar que
si la promesa se cumple, solo puede cumplirse para una única cadena s.
Así que siempre hay una sola
respuesta correcta a este problema.
Ese es el problema de Simon. Como dije, es difícil imaginar una situación práctica en la que quisieras resolver este problema,
pero ese no es el objetivo. El objetivo es intentar descubrir en qué son buenos los computadores cuánticos, y resulta que son muy superiores
a los algoritmos clásicos para
resolver este problema en particular.
Ahora echemos un vistazo
al algoritmo de Simon, que resuelve el problema de Simon.
El algoritmo consiste en
ejecutar el circuit cuántico que ves aquí varias veces, seguido de un paso de
posprocesamiento clásico,
y más adelante seremos más específicos sobre qué significa
"varias veces".
El circuit es muy similar
al circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa; esta vez, porque la función
f mapea n bits a m bits,
el gate de consulta es diferente. En lugar de un solo
qubit en la parte inferior, ahora tenemos m qubits abajo
y n arriba, como antes.
Una diferencia clave es que no
estamos preparando un estado menos o varios estados menos en la parte inferior.
Esos qubits inferiores se
inicializan todos al estado 0, y esos estados van directamente
al gate de consulta.
Por lo tanto, no habrá ningún phase kickback involucrado en este algoritmo; simplemente no es así como funciona este.
Más allá de las diferencias
que acabo de mencionar, sin embargo, se parece mucho al
circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa.
Aplicamos una capa de gates Hadamard, luego aplicamos un gate de consulta una vez, y después aplicamos otra
capa de gates Hadamard
seguida de mediciones en la base estándar de los n qubits superiores.
La idea es que cada vez que
ejecutamos este circuit y medimos, obtendremos alguna cadena y que nos dice algo
sobre la cadena oculta s
en el problema de Simon. Y ejecutando el circuit
varias veces de forma independiente, habremos reunido suficiente
evidencia estadística sobre s
para poder determinar cuál es
con alta confianza.
Ahora analicemos el quantum
circuit del algoritmo de Simon para ver qué hace.
El estado después de la primera
capa de Hadamard gates se ve así, similar a lo que teníamos para
el algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa.
Excepto que esta vez, los m qubits inferiores están todos en el estado 0
en lugar de estar en estados menos.
Después de aplicar el query gate, vemos que el valor f de x ha sido escrito en los
m qubits inferiores o del extremo izquierdo,
y eso es porque f de x ha sido aplicado mediante XOR sobre la cadena de todos ceros.
Entonces, de nuevo, no hay phase kickback en este algoritmo.
Luego aplicamos la segunda
capa de Hadamard gates.
Y usando la misma fórmula de antes para la acción de una
capa de Hadamard gates sobre un estado de la base estándar,
cat x en este caso,
como estaba en la fórmula original, obtenemos este estado aquí, donde la acción de los Hadamard gates
se ha hecho más evidente. Pero si queremos, también podemos escribir el estado
de una forma más compacta como tenemos aquí.
En este punto, medimos los n qubits superiores para obtener alguna cadena de n bits y, y solo necesitamos determinar
cuáles son las probabilidades
para las distintas cadenas. Y eso nos ayudará a entender
qué información obtenemos de esta cadena y sobre la cadena s
que está oculta dentro de la función f.
Vamos a necesitar
un poco más de espacio para esto, y realmente ya no necesitamos
el diagrama del circuit, así que deshagámonos de él y démosle
más espacio al análisis.
Aquí está el estado justo
antes de las mediciones, que son mediciones en la base estándar de los n qubits superiores o del extremo derecho.
Entonces la medición
corresponde al segundo cat.
Denotemos por p de y la probabilidad de que las mediciones nos den la cadena y para cada y posible.
Y si seguimos las reglas de la Lección 2, obtenemos que cada una de estas probabilidades es el cuadrado de la norma euclídea de cualquier vector que esté tensoriado
con el estado de la base estándar,
correspondiente a y en
nuestro vector de estado cuántico.
Eso nos da esta expresión aquí.
Ahora, para entender mejor
estas probabilidades, vamos a necesitar
usar cierta notación, y puede que ya te sea
familiar
porque es bastante común en matemáticas.
Primero, cuando hablamos del
rango de la función f, nos referimos simplemente al conjunto de todas las cadenas que pueden salir de esta función.
Es decir, el conjunto de todos los f de x variando sobre todas las posibles
elecciones de una cadena de entrada x.
Segundo, vamos a usar esta notación que ves aquí para referirnos al conjunto de todas las cadenas de entrada x
que f mapea a una cadena dada z, para cualquier elección de
z que queramos considerar.
Se parece un poco a la
inversa de la función f, pero no es realmente la inversa porque f no es necesariamente invertible.
También vemos que tenemos
un conjunto como argumento en el lado izquierdo, y en este caso es el conjunto que contiene
solo una cadena z,
y esa es la clave que necesitamos para reconocer que no estamos hablando de
la inversa de la función f; esto se llama la preimagen.
La preimagen puede
definirse de forma más general para cualquier conjunto dado como argumento, no solo el conjunto que contiene
un único elemento,
pero esto es todo lo que vamos a necesitar. No es la mejor
notación del mundo porque es fácil
confundirla con la inversa,
pero es suficientemente clara
y está ampliamente usada, así que nos quedamos con ella.
Y ahora, si usamos esta notación, podemos reescribir el vector del que estamos tomando el cuadrado de la norma euclídea para obtener la probabilidad de
medir cada cadena y.
Hacemos esto porque necesitamos ver
cuáles son los coeficientes de cada estado individual de la base estándar, y eso no queda claro a partir de
esta expresión aquí,
porque, en general, podemos
tener múltiples elecciones de x que nos dan la misma cadena f de x.
En esencia, lo único que hacemos
es dividir la suma sobre x sumando primero sobre todo
z en el rango de f,
y luego dentro de esa suma, sumando sobre todos los x en la preimagen de z, o para ser más precisos,
la preimagen del conjunto
que contiene la cadena z.
Eso nos permite reemplazar f de x por z dentro del cat aquí.
Y la suma sobre todas las distintas cadenas
x que f mapea a cada z se recoge en el
coeficiente de cada cat.
Básicamente estamos poniendo cadenas en contenedores, sumando sobre los contenedores y luego sumando sobre
las cadenas de cada contenedor,
pero eso es equivalente a simplemente
sumar sobre todas las cadenas.
Así que sí obtenemos una expresión equivalente a la
que teníamos al principio,
y ahora podemos calcular el
cuadrado de la norma euclídea.
Es simplemente la suma de los cuadrados de los valores absolutos
de los coeficientes, y así obtenemos esta expresión aquí
para nuestras probabilidades.
Por supuesto, tómate el tiempo
para verificar esto si decides hacerlo; lleva tiempo acostumbrarse a todo esto
y poder realizar
estos cálculos, y cuanto más practiques, más fácil te resultará.
Hasta ahora, en realidad no hemos
hecho uso de la promesa del problema de Simon en absoluto.
Nuestro análisis de estas probabilidades funciona para cualquier función f, pero ahora es momento de pensar en el problema de Simon
específicamente.
Vamos a dividir las cosas en los mismos dos casos
que tuvimos antes.
El primer caso es que s
es la cadena de todos ceros, y el segundo caso es que
s no es la cadena de todos ceros.
En el primer caso, que
s es la cadena de todos ceros, las cosas son bastante simples.
En este caso, como vimos antes, f es una función uno a uno, así que hay una sola cadena x
que se mapea a cada una de las
cadenas z en el rango de f.
Eso hace que el valor absoluto al cuadrado de la suma sobre esas cadenas sea igual a 1, porque hay solo
un único término en la suma,
que es más 1 o menos 1, pero no importa cuál, porque tomamos el
valor absoluto al cuadrado, y así obtenemos uno.
Hay 2 elevado a la n
elementos en el rango de f, y lo sabemos porque f es uno a uno, así que hay una cadena en el
rango por cada cadena de entrada.
Y si evaluamos la expresión completa, encontramos que cada cadena y aparece con probabilidad
uno sobre dos elevado a la n.
En otras palabras, las
mediciones nos dan una cadena y elegida uniformemente al azar.
Puede que eso no parezca muy útil, pero de hecho vamos a poder
distinguir este comportamiento del comportamiento que obtenemos en el caso
en que s no es la cadena de todos ceros, y veremos cómo funciona eso en breve.
Por ahora, simplemente observamos que si
f satisface la promesa en el problema de Simon en el caso en que s es la cadena de todos ceros,
entonces el resultado de las mediciones es una cadena aleatoria uniforme.
Ahora pasemos al segundo caso, que es que la promesa
se satisface para una cadena s que no es la cadena de todos ceros.
En este caso, como discutimos antes, cada cadena z en el rango de f tiene exactamente dos cadenas que se mapean a ella,
porque cada cadena tiene una pareja, y cada par de parejas
se mapea a alguna cadena única, y en concreto, la pareja de cada cadena
es la cadena que obtenemos al hacer XOR con s.
Así que si tomamos cualquier cadena
z en el rango de f, y le damos el nombre w a cualquiera de las
cadenas a las que f mapea a z,
entonces el XOR de w con s es la
otra cadena que se mapea a z.
Si miramos solo el término de nuestra suma que corresponde a cualquier cadena z del rango que tengamos en mente,
vemos que podemos
escribirlo de forma más explícita como se muestra aquí.
Tenemos dos cadenas en la preimagen de z: w y w con XOR con s.
Podemos escribir la suma
como ves en la pantalla, y lo que podemos hacer es factorizar un factor de
negativo 1 elevado a la potencia w.y.
Ese factor va a ser
más 1 o menos 1, así que desaparece cuando tomamos el valor absoluto,
y lo que nos queda es
esta expresión aquí.
Los detalles no se muestran todos aquí, y no es necesariamente
obvio que funcione de esta forma, pero puedes comprobar que estas
dos expresiones son iguales
volviendo a la definición
del producto punto binario y pensando en qué pasa cuando estas cosas están en
el exponente de negativo 1,
de manera similar a lo que tuvimos para el
problema de Bernstein-Vazirani.
Por último, podemos dividir esta
expresión en dos casos.
Es 4 cuando el producto punto binario
de s e y es 0, y es 0 cuando el producto punto
binario de s e y es 1.
Observa en particular que
no hay ninguna dependencia aquí en w o z; solo depende de s e y.
La razón por la que ocurre esto es
la naturaleza muy específica y especial de la promesa.
En esencia, esta es la razón por la que la promesa se formuló de esta manera, para que todo funcionara así.
De nuevo, cada cadena tiene una pareja, que obtenemos al hacer XOR con
esta cadena oculta s,
y eso es lo que hace que todo esto suceda.
Ahora podemos volver a la
expresión de las probabilidades y sustituir los valores.
Cuando s no es la cadena de todos ceros, hay 2 elevado a la n menos 1
elementos en el rango de f,
que es la mitad del
número de cadenas de entrada, y al sustituir los
valores que acabamos de calcular obtenemos esta fórmula aquí.
Así que esta vez, y no es una
cadena completamente aleatoria, sino que y es uniforme sobre exactamente la mitad de las cadenas de n bits,
y en concreto, es
uniforme sobre aquellas cadenas cuyo producto punto binario
con s es igual a 0.
Ahora que sabemos cómo funciona el circuit
del algoritmo de Simon y en concreto cuáles son las
probabilidades para los distintos resultados de medición,
nos queda explicar cómo esto nos ayuda a resolver el problema de Simon.
Resumiendo lo que acabamos de aprender, si se da el caso de que la función f satisface la promesa en el problema de Simon,
cuando la cadena oculta s
es la cadena de todos ceros, obtenemos una cadena completamente aleatoria de las mediciones,
donde cada cadena y de n bits
es igualmente probable.
Si, por otro lado, la función f satisface la promesa para una cadena s distinta, una que no es igual
a la cadena de todos ceros,
entonces obtenemos una cadena aleatoria y cuyo producto punto binario
es igual a 0 con s, y entre todas esas cadenas,
cada y es igualmente probable.
Pero nunca obtendremos una cadena y cuyo producto punto binario
sea igual a 1 con s.
La pregunta es: "¿Es esta información suficiente
para determinar s?" Y la respuesta, como ya
he sugerido, es sí,
siempre que ejecutemos el
circuit suficientes veces.
Específicamente, supongamos
que ejecutamos el circuit k veces, donde K es igual a n más r,
donde r es un número que va a controlar la
probabilidad de que recuperemos s.
Como ejemplo, si
elegimos r igual a 10, tendremos éxito con
una probabilidad mayor al 99.9%,
así que r no necesita ser muy grande.
En general, la probabilidad de fallo es menor que la probabilidad
de lanzar una moneda justa r veces y obtener cara todas las veces.
Entonces, si el 99.9% no es suficiente,
toma r igual a 20, y la probabilidad de fallo es
menor a una en un millón,
o elige el r que
te resulte cómodo. No puedes garantizar una solución correcta, pero puedes hacer que la
probabilidad de error sea despreciable
para todos los efectos prácticos.
Aquí nombramos estas
cadenas y1 hasta yk, donde usamos superíndices para ayudarnos a nombrarlas,
precisamente para poder reservar los subíndices para referirnos a los bits individuales
de esas cadenas.
Así que no son exponentes
ni nada por el estilo; son simplemente los nombres que le damos a estas k cadenas.
Cada una tiene longitud n porque las obtuvimos
al ejecutar el circuit del algoritmo de Simon.
Entonces podemos escribir los
bits individuales de estas k cadenas tal como se ve aquí.
Lo que hacemos ahora es crear una matriz m, donde cada entrada de esta matriz es un bit, y obtenemos estos bits de las cadenas
que acabamos de medir, tal como se muestra aquí.
Así que esta matriz tiene k filas y n columnas, y todas sus entradas son valores binarios.
Ahora bien, no sabemos qué es s. Eso es lo que intentamos encontrar, pero imaginemos por un
momento que sí lo supimos,
y formamos un vector columna
a partir de los bits de s, tal como se muestra aquí.
Si multiplicáramos ese vector por m y luego tomáramos el resultado módulo 2, o dicho de otra manera,
reemplazamos la suma
con la OR exclusiva, entonces necesariamente
obtendremos el vector todo ceros.
Eso es porque cada una de las
entradas de este vector resultante no es más que el
producto punto binario de s
con una de las filas de m.
Si s resulta ser la cadena todo ceros, siempre obtendremos el vector cero del producto punto binario.
Y si s no es la cadena todo ceros, obtendremos esto a partir de lo que
sabemos sobre las probabilidades de que aparezcan las cadenas y1 hasta yk.
En particular, el
producto punto binario con s siempre es cero para todas estas cadenas.
Una forma sencilla de decirlo es que este vector
formado por los bits de s siempre está en el espacio nulo
de la matriz m,
suponiendo que hacemos toda
nuestra aritmética módulo 2, pero claro, no sabemos qué es s,
estamos intentando encontrar s.
Pero lo que podemos hacer es calcular el
espacio nulo de esta matriz m, de nuevo, módulo 2.
Específicamente, podemos hacerlo usando la técnica de
eliminación gaussiana, que es el procedimiento que se suele enseñar
en los cursos introductorios de álgebra lineal.
Funciona perfectamente cuando hacemos toda nuestra aritmética módulo 2, y se puede realizar de manera bastante
eficiente con una computadora.
Y si calculamos el espacio nulo de m, dada la forma específica en que estas k cadenas han sido
elegidas aleatoriamente,
podremos recuperar s con una probabilidad mayor que
1 menos 2 elevado a menos r.
Para ser preciso, lo que veremos con una probabilidad mayor que
1 menos 2 elevado a menos r es que el espacio nulo
incluye el vector todo ceros,
como siempre ocurre con cualquier matriz, así como el vector correspondiente a s, ya sea el vector todo ceros o no.
Y lo más importante: ningún otro vector aparecerá
en el espacio nulo.
En realidad no es tan difícil demostrarlo, aunque no lo haré en detalle.
La idea es que si tenemos
alguna otra cadena que no es el vector todo ceros
y tampoco es s, entonces cada una de las cadenas aleatorias, y1 hasta yk,
básicamente la va a expulsar
del espacio nulo con probabilidad de un medio.
Así que después de k intentos, es muy poco
probable que sobreviva, y de hecho, ninguna de las
cadenas que no pertenecen
tiene probabilidades de sobrevivir. Y un hecho muy sencillo
de la teoría de probabilidades, conocido como la cota de la unión, puede
usarse para establecerlo.
No he explicado todos
los detalles aquí, pero espero que entiendas la idea de que al calcular el espacio nulo
módulo 2 de esta matriz m,
es muy probable que recuperemos s, y así es como el algoritmo de Simon
resuelve el problema de Simon.
Solo queda una cosa
por decir sobre el problema de Simon, y tiene que ver con la
dificultad clásica de este problema,
es decir, ¿cuántas consultas necesita un algoritmo de consulta clásico para resolver el problema de Simon?
La respuesta es: muchas, en general.
Hay diferentes enunciados precisos
que se pueden hacer sobre la dificultad clásica
de este problema, y aquí hay uno de ellos.
Si tenemos cualquier algoritmo
de consulta probabilístico y ese algoritmo realiza menos de 2 elevado a n sobre 2
menos 1, menos 1 consultas,
es decir, una cantidad de consultas
que es exponencial en n, entonces ese algoritmo fallará
en resolver el problema de Simon,
con probabilidad de al menos la mitad.
A veces, demostrar
resultados de imposibilidad como este puede ser muy difícil, pero este no es tan complicado de probar
mediante un análisis probabilístico
elemental.
No lo haré en esta lección en video, y en cambio me centraré
en la intuición detrás de esto.
Estamos intentando encontrar la cadena oculta s, pero mientras no consultemos la función en dos cadenas con
el mismo valor de salida,
obtendremos información muy
limitada sobre s.
Básicamente, lo único que aprendemos es
que la cadena oculta s no es la OR exclusiva de cualesquiera dos cadenas distintas
que hayamos consultado,
Y si consultamos la función con menos de esta cantidad de consultas, todavía habrá muchas posibilidades de s
que no habrán sido descartadas.
Esto no es una demostración formal,
pero esa es la idea básica.
En resumen, el algoritmo de Simon nos proporciona una ventaja notable de lo cuántico sobre los algoritmos
clásicos dentro del modelo de consultas.
En particular, el algoritmo
de Simon resuelve el problema de Simon con una cantidad de consultas que es lineal en el número de bits de
entrada n de nuestra función,
mientras que cualquier algoritmo clásico,
incluso si es probabilístico, necesita realizar una cantidad de
consultas que es exponencial en n
para resolver el problema de Simon con una probabilidad razonable de éxito.
Es cierto que el problema de Simon es un problema algo artificial que presumiblemente nadie
realmente quiere resolver,
pero eso es secundario. A veces las ideas necesitan desarrollarse antes de ponerse en práctica.
Y de hecho, Peter Shor ha declarado claramente que fue el algoritmo de Simon el que inspiró su ya
famoso algoritmo cuántico
para la factorización de enteros, que veremos en un par de lecciones.
Y ese es el final de la Lección 5.
En esta lección, hemos examinado el
modelo de consultas de computación, y hemos visto una progresión de ejemplos
de algoritmos cuánticos
que exhiben ventajas sobre los algoritmos clásicos
dentro de este modelo.
De hecho, se sabe mucho más
sobre el modelo de consultas y los algoritmos cuánticos para otros problemas que
no he discutido.
Así que si este
modelo te parece interesante, hay bastante más
que aprender sobre él.
Nuestro siguiente paso será alejarnos
del modelo de consultas y avanzar hacia un modelo de computación
que sea más representativo
del tipo de problemas que esperamos resolver en la práctica.
Espero que te unas a mí en la Lección 6, donde nos centraremos principalmente en
establecer las bases para estudiar algoritmos cuánticos.
Y a partir de ahí, pasaremos a algunos
algoritmos cuánticos específicos, incluyendo el algoritmo de Shor
para la factorización de enteros
en lecciones posteriores. ¡Hasta la próxima!